the point that's not the point I'm  making the point is that men are  attracted to Youth and Purity and the  problem is and and Beauty right and like  thin thinner women or curvy you know you  know slim that you know and so like the  point is there's a million women that  are pretty and Youthful there's a new  girl turning who doesn't have to be 18  let's give 22 every day okay let's go  more comfortable yeah we can there's  some studies that have said 21 22. I'm  just giving you one that kind of shows  the extreme and so the the point I'm  making is there's a lot of women that  want the top one percent of men and like  that's why most women are going to be  single and childless is